Nike co-founder Phil Knight declares war
on Democrats in Oregon
Phil Knight said he will do anything to
block Democrats from keeping their hold
on Oregon's Governor's seat Knight 84
has poured cash into the campaigns of
Democrats Tina kotec opponents and
Governor's race he helped to kick-start
a campaign for Betsy Johnson a former
Democrat running as an independent who
is serving as a major supporter to kotec
Johnson's candidacy has given Republican
Christine Drazen the opportunity she
needs in a liberal electorate no longer
confident in the State uh recent
far-left policies won the political uh
cartoons after our legislative session
had a person snorting cocaine out of a
mountain of White Knight said Saturday
it said which of these is illegal in
Oregon and the answer was the plastic
straw yeah I'll tell you one thing do
you remember a couple years ago Oregon
legalized or decriminalized all drugs
all drugs that's the one state in the
country where
whatever you want have at it and
ironically what's illegal not the pound
of cocaine the plastic straw that you
can do the cocaine from it's very ironic
I think I think this is sort of a sign
of the times if this is like a canary in
the coal mine very weird you know
Phil Knight Oregon Nike they're not
exactly the most conservative people or
conserve a company Colin Kaepernick yeah
basically they they were behind Colin
Kaepernick but it just goes to show how
far left Oregon has gone and they're in
need of an over correction yeah I don't
think people understand just how rough
the the general citizens of Portland had
after all of that stuff settled out Chas
yeah that City or whatever yeah though
the whole thing I mean it was just
terrible and you get citizens in Oregon
now the reason this is close isn't
because of Phil's money it's close
because there's a lot of citizens out
there and Phil's money and the citizens
who are being pulled they're like this
is the wrong direction this one the
violent pendulum you're talking to and
remember this is also Oregon the state
that when a large whale was beached and
rotting the solution was to blow it up
with dynamite so you have to remember
the legacy of Oregon if anybody wants to
go look on on the Oregon whale that the
highway department blew up with dynamite
and this is ladies and gentlemen this is
your Oregon you get what you vote for
and I mean you gotta go back and vote
for something else so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]